on March 4th 2022 Microsoft announced
that they had completed a$ 19.7 billion
cash acquisition their second largest
acquisition of all time what company did
they buy you ask maybe LinkedIn GitHub
or activation blizzard well it was
actually a company that you've probably
never heard of Nuance Communications on
the surface Nuance is a speech
recognition and speech synthesis company
so you would naturally think that Nuance
is some sort of AI based Voice Assistant
Play something like Siri or Alexa
probably to make Cortana better but that
wasn't why Microsoft bought Nuance well
then maybe they bought Nuance as a
chatbot play speech synthesis technology
could be a massive help for chat GPT to
form natural sentences and paragraphs
but that wasn't why Microsoft bought
Nuance either well in that case Nuance
must have been a market share play right
Nuance must have controlled a massive
portion of the Market within the speech
technology World well that's partially
true in that Nuance was indeed a market
share play but not in the way that you
might expect Nuance didn't have massive
market share against any of the
traditional players whether it be Google
assistant or chat GPT in fact Nuance
doesn't have all that much to do with
the traditional tech industry in general
but then again it's not like Microsoft
needs that much help in this area anyway
and that's why the Nuance deal was
actually about breaking into a
completely different industry one that
Microsoft doesn't control the healthcare
industry you see over the past few
decades Nuance has built a reputation as
the go-to platform for hospitals and
physicians in fact 55% of Physicians 75%
of Radiologists and 77% of American
hospitals use Nuance Solutions so by
purchasing Nuance Microsoft immediately
became the dominant player within the
healthcare industry but all of that is
just the beginning as Microsoft has much
grander Ambitions with with Nuance so
here's why Microsoft really spent $20
billion to buy a no-name
[Music]
company a lot of us probably discount
the healthcare sector because it's not
exactly the most shiny or glamorous they
don't have massive product launches like
Apple or Google nor do they have the
same brand or reputation but the
healthcare industry is one of those
background Giants that's actually
extremely powerful in fact even more
powerful than the tech industry in the
US for example Healthcare accounts for
over 18% of the national GDP or about
$4.3 trillion per year for perspective
the tech industry is only half as large
accounting for only 99.3% of the
American GDP or just under $2 trillion
but not only is the healthcare industry
already massive but they're expected to
continue growing at a record pace of
5.4% over the next decade Tech on the
other hand has actually been on a
decline in terms of GDP contribution in
fact 2022 was lower than 2017 and given
that Microsoft is already one of the
largest players within the tech industry
it's no wonder why they're trying to
expand their Horizons to other massive
Industries but ironically Nuance didn't
start off as a healthcare-based tech
company or a profit oriented business in
general they actually traced their Roots
all the way back to 1974 to a man named
Raymond ctsw to be honest I've never
heard of Raymond till now but looking
into his background this man is
absolutely stacked not in terms of
wealth like other people we cover but in
terms of contributions the man is a
first class academic scholar and
inventor with dozens and dozens of
contributions that companies have gone
on to commercialize to great success
just to give you a sense of his
accomplishments Ry has earned 21
honorary doctorates honors from three US
presidents and is named as one of the 16
revolutionaries that made America and
even before he founded the the precursor
to Nuance Communications Ry was doing
massive things it turns out that while
he was in college he managed to create
an application sorting software that
could match high school students with
colleges and he would go on to sell this
company shortly after for $100,000 plus
royalties which is the same as $750,000
2020 so it's safe to say that Ray was
financially set by the time that he was
in his mid-20s but that didn't stop him
from inventing which brings us into
Kurtz swah computer Products Inc in 197
before Ray's goal with this company was
to create the world's first omn font
optical character recognition software
you're probably familiar with Apple's
live text feature that they launched a
few years ago live text allows you to
copy text from images and this is
precisely the technology that Ray was
developing only 50 years ago he would
succeed within just a year actually but
there was one major problem Ry had no
obvious way to monetize this invention
worse he was focusing on applications
that weren't all that lucrative though
they were Noble their first application
for example was to create the world's
first print dis speech reading machines
for the blind while this invention did
earn them some notoriety on the news it
didn't provide them with all that much
revenue in fact Ry admits that by 1978
they were scrambling to raise funds and
as such they would pivot into more
commercial applications of this
technology such as scanning documents
into databases and this endeavor would
catch the attention of the tech leader
of the time Xerox Xerox had spent
decades figuring out how to convert
digital text into physical text and the
startup had built a bridge backwards so
this technology fit perfectly into
xerox's Arsenal and they would buy the
company in 1980 for a modest $3.6
million but all of this was just the
beginning the Xerox acquisition didn't
really change anything about ctsw
computer products because Xerox was a
pretty chill company in fact they were
were probably way too chill for their
own good if you didn't know Xerox
basically missed out on multiple hundred
billion dollar opportunities that they
created from laptops and computers to
Microsoft Office and object-oriented
programming how you ask well Xerox was
never all that concerned about
protecting their intellectual property
or commercializing these insane
inventions largely because they were
overconfident in their photocopying
business which eventually got destroyed
but while this mindset wasn't all that
great for zerox as a whole it was great
for kurts while he basically had the
freedom to experiment with whatever he
wanted and Xerox would Bank all his
efforts and let's just say Ray took full
advantage of this instead of focusing on
Commercial applications Ray would revert
to focusing on text to speech for the
blind he would Implement compatibility
for several languages including French
German Italian Spanish and Swedish and
he would package all of this technology
into a streamlined product the Kurtz
swall personal reader which launched in
April of 1988 the Kurtz swall personal
reader was was by no means cheap coming
in at $8,000 to
$112,000 but that was simply how much it
cost to build such technology back in
the 80s as Windows computers started to
gain popularity Ray would bring this
technology to Windows as well through a
piece of software called text Bridge fun
fact this software is still available on
xerox's website to this day though it
hasn't been updated in nearly 20 years
but while text Bridge lives on to this
day Ry wouldn't stick around at Xerox
for much longer 1995 Ry would leave to
create Kurtz wall Educational Systems
which focused on helping people with
dyslexia and ADHD but while Ray was no
longer involved in the picture Kurtz
computer products would continue to
evolve and grow under Xerox it was known
as Xerox Imaging systems before becoming
scansoft honestly it would have been in
xerox's best interest to hold on to
scansoft for as long as possible but
let's not forget these are the same
people that sold their 5 to 8% stake in
Apple for just $1.2 million
so it's not all that surprising that
Xerox dropped a ball with scansoft as
well selling them off visioner in 1998
from there scansoft would engage in a
series of Acquisitions and mergers to
expand their product portfolio from just
text recognition to speech recognition
likely the most notable of these
Acquisitions was Nuance for $220 million
in 2005 Nuance was a relatively new
company that had launched a hit product
named Dragon Naturally Speaking in
1997 as the name suggests Dragon
Naturally Speaking was focused on
deciphering voice commands speech to
text and text to speech technically
dragon is a Windows software that
basically anyone can get if they want
but for the most part Dragon was
something that was recommended by
doctors and Healthcare Providers to
people with various disabilities and
when scansoft acquired Nuance they
decided to take on their name leading to
the creation of Nuance
Communications over the years noan
managed to go pretty large in terms of
market cap but their vision and purpose
was never really clouded despite being
in the extremely lucrative industry of
healthcare and controlling 77% of the
market newans never really made all that
much money themselves even at their Peak
they were only pulling in $2 billion for
perspective a United Health Group the
largest insurance provider in America
pulls in $324 billion per year so it
turns out that the company that's
supposed to be protecting Americans from
large medical bills is pulling in
hundreds of billions per year while the
company actually helping people with
disabilities is only pulling in 2
billion and that's just from a revenue
perspective if you look at net income
you'll see that Nuance has basically
never been consistently profitable
they've maintained more of a break even
Financial profiler earning or losing 100
$200 million in any given year and this
is precisely why so many people are
worried about the Microsoft acquisition
noan says historically been a company
with very Noble intentions wealth was
something that always followed for them
not not something that led and people
are worried that this will change with
Microsoft's influence I mean there's no
question that Microsoft's intentions
with Nuance are very opportunistic they
basically saw that this company was
killing it within the healthcare
industry something that most tech
companies had no control over so they
went ahead and bought Nuance not to
control speech recognition or whatever
but to win influence over the healthcare
industry over the past 50 years Nuance
has built deep long-lasting
relationships with thousands of
hospitals and hundreds of thousands of
doctors this gives them the perfect
opportunity to use these connections to
push Microsoft Azure to the entire
healthcare industry and given that
Microsoft has an entire website about
how Microsoft cloud can be used for
healthcare it does seem like this is
their real angle with Nuance with that
being said though Microsoft does have a
history of being very lenient with your
Acquisitions whether it's LinkedIn or
GitHub Microsoft pretty much gives them
full reign of how to run their companies
in fact it's almost as if these
companies are completely independent of
Microsoft and given that nuance's CEO
Mark Benjamin has stuck around it seems
that relations between nuance and
Microsoft are going pretty well so it
may be the case that Microsoft is bling
to let Nuance do whatever they want when
it comes to speech recognition while
banking all of their operations all
Microsoft wants in return is some
business from nuance's Healthcare
customers and that's why Microsoft spent
$20 billion buying a no-name company
with historically High interest rates
the appeal of bills and bonds is higher
than ever yet traditional brokerages
haven't really adapted with the times
they still expect people to use clunky
Bond tables scroll through long
overwhelming lists and even use Virtual
keyboards till recently and that's why
we created our own modern Bond platform
Silo at Silo we prioritize the user
experience and the ease of finding an
investing in the issuers you know and
trust so that you too can easily lock in
high yields also choosing a strong user
experience does not mean sacrificing
unsafety every Salo account is ensured
by $500,000 in sipc insurance and a $2.5
million in FDIC Insurance also all funds
deposited on the platform will be
maintained by our trusted custodian
interactive brokers who has experienced
managing $373 billion worth of assets
over the past 45 years so if you're
looking for a modern way to invest in
bonds please consider checking out Silo
in the description below do you think
this is a fair deal comment that down
below Microsoft is also making some
major moves within the social media
space check out this video to learn more
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next
one